vanessa bryant knows strong jeans run in
the family
on tuesday the proud mama shared a
precious photo of her youngest daughters
bianca
and capri pointing out the resemblance
to their late father kobe bryant
in the picture taken during the family's
outing to san diego zoo safari park
the two were twinning in black outfits
seemingly mesmerized by the animals
which
totally reminded us of kobe's intense
focus on the basketball court
one of the amazing things i've watched
is you maintain your focus
on basketball how do you do that with
the swirl of activity around you how do
you do it
you know it's uh it's just god-given
this is god-given just you know do
prayer
he always gives you the strength when
you need it the most so
i can't take credit for that the mama 4
captioned the sweet shot
game faces daddy's twins the bryant
family got
up close and personal with the wildlife
the girls enjoyed their time with
giraffes
rhinos monkeys and even tigers
[Music]
yes
good job
[Laughter]
yeah that's brave coco making sure that
tiger
didn't miss a meal
on the same weekend vanessa and her
girls also took over sea world
here's bianca all smiles as she greeted
a dolphin she has a special button
[Music]
vanessa also showed some love to a
beluga well and
fed some turtles
the adventurous weekend comes after
vanessa's oldest daughter natalia went
to her senior prom
the 18 year old was pretty in pink
sharing behind the scenes moments from
the night like
this cute tic toc
[Music]
she also posted a photo of a pink
balloon-filled room
that her proud mom set up just for her
the special milestone was on the same
day as
kobe bryant's nba hall of fame induction
i wish my husband was here to accept
this incredible award he and gigi
deserve to be here to witness this
natalia wasn't able to attend her dad's
ceremony but vanessa shared
why it was important for her daughter to
make it to her prom
the mom of four shared a story on
instagram writing about a time where she
and kobe couldn't attend prom
as the basketball player had a playoff
game the same night
she jokingly told natalia quote daddy
kept me from going to my prom
so it's only right that he tried to keep
you from going to yours
of course we laughed because even in
heaven he's still trying to make moves
and keep the boys away
and despite it being the nba legends big
night vanessa didn't want her daughter
to miss
out on the once in a lifetime
opportunity kobe had many
accomplishments
but his most cherished accomplishment
was being the very best girl dad
vanessa attended the hall of fame event
alongside her bff lala anthony
who's been there for the bryant family
the whole way through e.t spoke with
lala where she didn't hold back from
praising vanessa for being such a strong
person
i tell her every day she's the strongest
woman i know and um
i'm really really proud of just how
she's handling everything
and just want to continue to be there
you know as much as i can for her as a
friend she's just
an amazing and amazing human being just
just amazing